so first move is
here okay so you
you already have him on his toes
so first move boom keep this locked
then you'll lower yourself
and your head will go here and you'll
see that's
also another lock that's
he wants to go around me
so boom
then my still on the lock is still on
i get my head into it and i go to
another lock
[Music]
one two head is doing it
as he came in with that first one i'm
over here
see so if you if you look at his
his grip is straight but when he does
the push
i'm going to use that energy to get his
grip to change
you see and i'm now in in this thing
okay i'm moving here
and once once i get that grip i make his
elbow go
under me you see his elbows underneath
and now i can get him
on his toes but it's not that i'm going
like that i'm just using the ground path
you see it's over here
so he's coming in you're basically doing
this
okay so once once you get him here he's
higher
he's not down and you're trying to
he's up here you see and
his energy is going this way
because that's the spiral so he's going
that way
that's the way i go and then
doing the push i yield change the grip
he's going that way i keep him going
that way
with the lock and now with my head
this would be wrong
nothing until now
warm up
okay